all right everybody it is time for
drew's news that daily whiff of that
fresh baked good news pie
i'm with me at the desk is my little
pumpkin pie rusty rust mat
hi everybody hi
hi
all right first we're gonna jump ahead
to christmas for a minute ross do you
remember rockefeller the little stowaway
owl that they found in the rockefeller
center christmas tree never forget
little rockefeller look how cute show of
hands who remembers rockefeller uh we
were obsessed okay i like i wanted to
know if almost rockefeller was single
you know like
i wanted to like move in with him and
just live happily ever after yeah
i wish you well
i know it's true i i have
but
this is so exciting because
syracuse.com reports that little rocky
just inspired her own children's book
it's called the christmas owl and it
follows her harrowing journey from a
forest upstate to new york city and then
to an animal sanctuary to her regaining
her strength before she went back home
to the wild again if she moved in with
us she would have to she wouldn't have
to go to the wild oh it's going to be a
best seller it's going to fly off the
shelves
well i love her and guess what i am
going to purchase a copy and i'm going
to read it with um my two daughters
olive and frankie and i just want to
thank that publisher
who thought you know what this is a good
idea i have to say you're right all
right from uh well this is a weird
transition but from an owl to turkey day
we eat birds um
sorry let me do it different
oh no it's great i'm i'm trying to i'm
like a rockefeller and now you're gonna
eat the next animal this is perfect
i feel better now do you want to date or
get eaten it's your choice
well turkey day means hours and hours
for family conversation which have you
ever been to dinner during thanksgiving
it can get real awkward when the
family's around you don't want to step
in some gravy we've got some tips for
you pure wow to put together a list of
things not repeat not to say on
thanksgiving oh i can't wait to hear
every single one of these so give it to
me now okay they say it's gonna be real
awkward if you say things like this hey
so when are you getting married
don't ask that and i'm planning right
now so please don't ask me because i
don't know
don't ask me this question either uh
when are you having kids
uh or this one well don't ask uncle
larry if he's still in the closet don't
do that i don't recommend he'll let you
know when he's ready what about this one
they say you're supposed to say oh
you've really lost weight or you've
really gained weight don't say that the
other thing to avoid i think don't ask
anyone who they're voting for that could
get real awkward real quick it's true
you know it's funny though i
i i'm okay with that kind of chatter
like i'm okay with everybody talking
about their differences at the table
like why are we pretending we're all the
same person
okay that's sweet i just want to get it
over with i'm like
like yeah i just great great cranberry
sauce aunt helen see you next year
rays of hands
who loves their family but shenanigans
will ensue at thanksgiving
i love this
i love it
it's so fun i mean i'm telling you you
could be alone and
feeling awkward or you could be with
your family feeling awkward take your
pick yeah or you could be on a date with
an owl
i'm like rockefeller
we're going to have you for dinner
oh wow
well
next
one of my favorite things about
thanksgiving is that turkey day aroma it
just hangs in the air oh yeah oh do you
smell it and now southern living reports
that you can get it without lifting a
single pot with the new thanksgiving
feast candle that's right
it smells like buttery mashed potatoes
sage stuffing and cranberry sauce are
you ready we're gonna take a whiff i'm
very scared to smell it
okay
yeah i like it i like it it doesn't
necessarily smell meaty but it smells
thanksgiving-y yeah it's the more like
floral aspect of
how do you feel about food-scented
candles in general um i'm
is it
was i asking you no i'm kidding yeah
but like what if i told you because your
favorite food in the world is mac and
cheese what if i said oh they also made
a mac and cheese scented candle are you
excited say
bring me a
spoon um
no they also make a mac and cheese
scented candle and i have one right here
for you my love
oh
it doesn't really smell like macaroni
and cheese
it smells like something oh god
this i i think this candle is just
perfect
next it's time to review the things that
you want us to in drew's review okay
and today we're trying a turkey day
invention suggested by meg marin via
instagram thank you meg for writing to
us and you want us to try
leftover thanksgiving nachos
okay i have to say i've never heard of
this has anyone here ever heard of this
no but i like all those words in it
thanksgiving leftovers nachos all right
let's do this okay
so it's it's chips with like the turkey
yeah i know i feel like why am i eating
stuffing pork
okay hold on and then there's okay
i didn't realize there was nacho cheese
on top of it
hey meg
drew can date an owl i'm gonna date you
okay this is
phenomenal
wow this is nacho ordinary nacho
here's my thoughts okay
i love everything except for the cheese
oh really yeah because it just it throws
everything off the chips with
the thanksgiving flavors are amazing but
the cheese i don't know it's standing in
the way for me i feel like i don't even
know you anymore
because um the cheese makes it for me oh
really yeah takes it to nacho brings it
together says come on board wear a nacho
now get into it
well meg i couldn't have come up with
any of this without you so i'm gonna
give it three out of five turkeys all
right okay
i gotta give it up to you meg for
inventiveness
[Music]
you